tanks unmanned ground Vehicles
ammunition
this is one of the largest defense
industry fairs in the Eurasia region
more than 50 countries are here looking
for business in New Markets
many many visitors from all over the
world whether from Africa Middle East
Latin America Europe and Asia also as
well so that's the reason that we are
here today to show the world what kind
of Defense industries that turkey is
able to supply
turkey is revenue from defense exports
Rose by 42 percent between 2020 and
2021.
with foreign contracts making up as much
as 90 percent of sales for some
companies
we're producing in four main groups
people
ammunition rocket and explosive and
Machinery gas groups our products are
mostly used by Turkish army forces as
well as we are exporting them to some
countries it is exists 60 countries in
all over the world especially in Asia
gulf countries and also in African
countries
in 2022 turkey hit a record 4.4 billion
dollars in arms exports a figure larger
than some European countries annual
defense budgets the Turkish government
aims to bring that figure to 6 billion
in 2023 by exporting more defense
products but it is drones in particular
that have been created
elevates turkey status as a player in
the global defense industry but also as
a leverage in its foreign relations
Istanbul